[Music]
her lips have been the most requested
lips that people want to look like so
her wanting to take it out is a really a
big to-do so here's the before and after
of Kylie's lip read ooh on Sunday the 20
year old confess I got rid of all my
filler why well our source says it's all
about baby stormy stormy it reminds me
she's my twin the one thing I was
insecure about she has she has the most
perfect lips
we're told quote once stormy was born
Kiley realized she was a mother first
during the pregnancy Kiley wasn't
getting her usual fillers or putting on
much makeup and she really fell in love
with the natural look dr. Stephen if who
does not treat kylie showed us how it's
done
all it takes as one session which cost
about $500 you know start off by numbing
up the lips we mix up the solution we'll
inject it in the place where there was
the filler and what he'll do is he'll
just dissolve it filler your body will
metabolize it away well Kylie's not the
only star to pump their palate and then
change their mind on a ferret stop
getting injections because she didn't
notice much of a difference Jessica
Simpson didn't like it Klein Bullock
fake but Kylie's move could be a
game-changer for her 111 million fans
and followers Kylie Jenner being such a
hint porn sir she's not doing it they
may not want to do it either
you
[Music]